las operaciones de rescate seguían este
viernes en una mina de Carbón de amasta
en el norte de Turquía decenas de
personas permanecían bloqueadas tras una
explosión que ocurrió mientras los
obreros estaban trabajando
110 de nuestros hermanos estaban
trabajando en la mina algunos de ellos
los de niveles superiores lograron salir
justo después de esta explosión otros
han sido rescatados
los rescatistas intentaban sacar a los
mineros que seguían atrapados en las
Galerías mientras los familiares
esperaban ansiosamente afuera la
explosión se produjo a 300 metros por
debajo de la entrada de la mina según
los expertos podría haber sido provocada
por una acumulación de grisú un gas que
se desprende del Carbón y que provoca
explosiones por su alto contenido en
metano
el sistema de ventilación de nuestras
Galerías funciona actualmente de forma
adecuada algunas zonas están
parcialmente colapsadas la primera
evaluación realizada por nuestros
equipos indica que la explosión fue
causada por grisuno
el presidente y perdón visitará este
sábado el lugar del incidente los
accidentes de trabajo son frecuentes en
Turquía especialmente en la construcción
y la explotación mineral donde las
normas no suelen ser respetadas en 2014
una explosión y un incendio provocaron
la muerte de 301 mineros en suma en el
oeste del país